Now let us consider, the processing of the fourth example comes along.
Again the red outline shows that this is a negative example of the constant.
Because this is a negative example, we must specialize in most journal
concept characterizations available at the moment. We can begin by checking,
whether we need to specialize this particular general concept. But wait,
this general concept characterization, already excludes the negative example.
This says the earlier happens when I go to Sam's, and this has Bob's in it, so
this already excludes it, I don't have to specialize it any more.
Now let's look at this general model. Does this need to be specialized,
in order to excluded? Yes, because at the current stage, this includes this
vertical example. It is cheap here, this is cheap, this is any here, and this
has particle elements within. This means that, this concept characterization,
must be specialized in a way that excludes this negative example and yet.
The new specialization, is consistent with the most specialized characterization
at present. It is tempting to see the two pathways as converging here,
because this is identical to that, but we also have this branch hanging, and
this branch says that I'm allergic to any meal at Sam's, not just a cheap meal.
So, we're not done yet. In this state there is one other element to consider.
If there is a node, that lies on a pathway starting from the most journal
concept characterization, that is subsumed by a node, that comes from
another pathway starting from the same journal concept characterization, then I
want to prune that particular node. The reason I wanted to put on this note is,
because this note is subsumed by this note. So this note is true,
I don't have to carry this around. If I'm allergic to any meat at Sam's,
I don't have to specify that I'm allergic to cheap meat at Sam's, thus I can
pull on this particular pathway, and I've left it only this particular pathway.
At this point in processing, these are the examples that have been encountered
so far. There are only two possible. I'm either allergic to everything at Sam's,
or I'm allergic to every cheap meal at Sam's.